right yeah so ipagamine hypergamy is  that women want to date are constantly  trying to date up no no no no wait wait  wait wait wait wait wait wait women are  constantly trying to date up they're  trying to get trying to get the best  deal that they can get men men will get  a deal and be like you know what I'm  actually quite happy with this and hang  on let me finish men will get a deal  they will get a woman who's a six out of  ten that she ticks all the boxes and  they will Coast for the rest of their  life wait wait wait  so women are always looking for that  level up right which is why which is why  if I was to ask all of you women here  right now the types of men that you want  you would probably list a man in the top  20 of men right but if you're listening  to Madison the top 20 of men what's  gonna happen is what if a man comes up  he's in the top 15 well if a man that  comes in the top 10 percent